By adding Marvel to our slate of Disney Pixar and Pixar films,..
...we will, in the coming year, be making movies under three of the best known labels in family entertainment.
These brands resonate with consumers globally and give us a competitive advantage...
...in a world of nearly limitless choices.
We will also continue to focus our investment on franchise properties...
...like Princess and the Frog, Cars 2, Toy Story 3 and Pirates 4.
When our franchise films are successful, they create a wave across the company...
...that can lift up all of our Disney-branded businesses.
While it remains a challenging time, it's also a very exciting one.
Our parks and resorts business is expanding with the addition of attractions that bring together great creativity...
...and fantastic new technologies at Disney's California Adventure,...
...at Hong Kong Disneyland, and at the Magic Kingdom at Walt Disney World.
Work is well underway on our new family resort in Hawaii...
...and on two magnificent new cruise ships...
...whose design we unveiled a couple of weeks ago in New York.